um okay so you're obviously doing your
thing you have this record what
transpires to get cardi B well you want
her radar and obviously the song because
that obviously is a life-changing moment
a career changing moment
um
so
when
um
when cardi B manager reached out to me
to hop on the record
I'm like what the [__] I thought it was
a joke I didn't even think it was
serious because you know Carly she real
big like one of the biggest biggest you
know female I'm like the biggest artist
period period [__] female male period
you feel me so I I just really thought
that was like
Next Level uh another level and a whole
nother level type of thing like oh she
heard my lyrics She wanna get on the
song she heard the song it was um
literally a life changing but when they
reached out to me I'm like man
get back to them ASAP I told my manager
reach it back out to them ASAP and um
she did exactly that and
we got on the phone me and cardi we end
up getting on the phone and we was
discussing it she loved the song she was
like I loved it she was so sweet and
nice about it all and um I'm like you
know
do it in LA do the video in LA
she like
no
we coming to Chicago we going to Chicago
so that was like a whole another like
okay exactly I want to make it easy for
you so where do I go to you is that the
video and then she like you I'm coming
to your city you just got them you just
gotta lead and I'm a follower it was lit
I'm like what the [__]
that was the best I was a video shoot I
mean I mean would you guys have fun or
was it was it we had we had a ball we
had fun like we've had past fun when you
guys first met was it obviously you
talked on the phone but when you guys
first meet it's like Cardi's also one of
those people who's
exactly who you think she is yeah she's
incredible she she exactly who she was
on that phone yeah so um we was I was
actually getting ready and I think she
was out doing her scene you know and it
was like come on Fendi you gotta go do a
single cardi and this was my first time
you know we didn't even meet like you
know we ain't even go to the back or
none of that we just they was just like
go ahead get in the scene and it was
like a throw in the scene and I hopped
in and she was like oh my God you so
pretty and we hooked and it just went
from there that's amazing yes like
it's just slick have you like because
you always I feel like when you have
a quick
trajectory like the last month of your
life has been
yeah there has to be some like have you
seen the hate coming from like because
usually you get the most hate from your
hometown right yeah yeah yeah has there
been like like any of that that you have
to deal with in terms of like
maybe people acting different or acting
a little jealous or yeah like even at
the video shoot
it was just like love
hate but it got real like afterwards
after the video dropped
the hay got real but it's like I'm used
to it right
for sure it got real would you like uh
because I feel like a lot of people
who are from Chicago eventually end up
maybe getting a place somewhere else
still going home maybe keep a crib you
know a home base now that you're getting
bigger are you considering pivoting out
of you know because you know like at the
end of the day like like I said some of
the greatest artists we've had ever have
lost their lives in their Hometown think
about Dolph Nipsey it would go on and on
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I'm definitely thinking about
um moving
I ain't trying to lose my life and
nobody else Hometown but I'm definitely
thinking about moving for sure